it's time for stuntmen scary movie night
now this is a spoiler filled review just
to warn you big spoilers if you haven't
seen signs skip this review welcome to
another edition of stuckman scary movie
night last time we talked about John
Carpenter's The Thing this time we're
going to talk about one of my favorite
movies of all time M night Shyamalan z'
signs I laughed because now when you say
that name it's not as powerful and
joining me in this special review is my
good buddy Mark Ellis over the schmoes
no Christian had to fight a dinosaur
somewhere on King Kong Island hey
everyone it's Mark Ellis on loan from
schmoes no and I am thrilled to be
joining Chris duck means scary movie
night I love scary movies I'm a big
horror fan I do get scared I'm not like
a tough guy I get very spooked watching
scary movies and luckily I'm in an
apartment complex I live by myself but I
have nice neighbors next door that
occasionally become look in the closet
in case there's you know anything in
there I'm very happy that Chris asked me
on this episode because we're talking
about signs and signs is one of my
favorite movies of this century believe
it or not kids there is a time when you
saw M night Shyamalan s name attached to
a movie and you got excited you got a
jolt just being in the theater awaiting
what was going to happen it's fit hasn't
been that way quite since the sense
signs but I like it M night's career to
a pitcher who came out and he was young
and he was just a flame thrower throw
100 mile an hour fast balls every time
he was on the mound and then he made the
village and he threw his arm out we
heard a pop he had Tommy John surgery we
don't know if he's ever gonna be the
same again I'm an optimist so I'm
holding out hope but I did see the last
airbender so you gotta wonder
you
a lot of people are aware the fact that
science is one of my favorite movies and
also science is actually the movie that
got me into film criticism and
independent filmmaking and a few people
have been like signs really signs yes
signs I don't know if you ever noticed
this but science poster right there in
every single review when I saw signs in
2002 and by the way this is actually the
first DVD I ever bought interesting fun
fact when I saw that film in 2002 it had
such an impact on me because up until
that point I had kind of viewed films
purely as entertainment and I wasn't
looking at them from a logistical
standpoint I wasn't looking at how they
were made the craft the filmmaking until
that movie that movie I saw five times
in theaters and it made me really start
to look at film and how film is crafted
and that's one of the reasons why I owe
a lot that movie in fact you probably
would not even be watching this video
right now if I hadn't gone to scene
signs that day and it's big enough
people who we may not view in the same
light as we used to Mel Gibson is the
star of signs and this is pre all the
stupid tabloid TMZ stuff that I really
don't care about this is Mel Gibson when
everybody knew he was one of the best
actors in the business
it was bankable you knew you're getting
a hit when he was in it so these two
forces collaborating on oh by the way an
alien crop circle movie that's got epic
written all over it and it did not
disappoint I saw this movie opening
night in the theater with me my brother
went to go see it to this new movie
theater there was like 45 minutes away
from Williamsburg Virginia which at that
time had a blacksmith shop and that's
about it
so we see the movie we park way out at
the end of the parking lot and there's a
big wooded area right so we see the
movie and you know there's aliens hiding
in crops and stuff we were so spooked at
walking out of this theater I'm like I
don't want to walk in my car there's
like woods right there and I'm trying to
do the math if an alien popped out and
attacked me would I have water in my
hand but I feel I get into the car in
time
I remember one of the latter times I saw
this in theaters I brought my sister
with me whenever it would get dark in
the movie she would just freak out and
like go to my shoulder but at the end of
the movie I remember we were walking
outside and it's strange just like what
Ella said in his story there was a
forest like nearby the theater and I
like got down on my knees and I made
little clicking sounds and my sister was
freaking out and it was just it was
great really the reason I like this
movie so much is is it's half nostalgia
it's largely just the fact that it is a
movie that made me realize and
appreciate cinema because as I was a kid
growing up I always loved movies I mean
Star Wars The Princess Bride Toy Story
Lion King loved movies as I grew up as a
kid Back to the Future but when I saw
science something in me just went oh
movies are made by a group of people and
it just made me it just made me think
about the craft of making a movie and
that's one of the reasons I really
appreciate signs when people criticize
signs is they say oh really
aliens are gonna go visit a planet
that's 70% water when that kills them uh
yeah they may actually do that maybe
they're really interested in the other
30% of that planet okay maybe they want
oil maybe they want to go to chick-fil-a
I don't know guys but there's a lot of
times when if you want something really
bad you're gonna have to go to a very
dangerous place to get it looking guys
with strip clubs every time we walk into
one of those we know there's like ten a
hundred things that were allergic to but
there's also things in that club that
you just can't get anywhere else and we
need our natural resources there's so
many great thrills you get with this
movie that's maybe my favorite thing
about signs is how perfectly paced it is
is you get a little creepy review maybe
see something hey what was that and then
maybe you see a leg and you see green on
green you don't know what's going on yet
and then the invasion starts to happen
and the scene of all scenes in signs is
the birthday party there they run this
footage on the news where this is like
okay now we know it's aliens there's
these kids
a birthday party somewhere in South
America and they get on tape the alien
walking across the driveway and my
goodness
usually this is when hard films kind of
fall apart is when you see what this bad
antagonist is and then you're like oh
that's what Candyman looks like now we
can defeat him but when you see this
creature you actually are more freaked
out than you were during the build-up
and that is incredibly rare thing in
cinema and that is why I will always
have faith in a night Shyamalan that's
that that scene still it scares the crap
out man was around the count even acting
funny some of them violent sometimes
like they actually smell a predator
around come on I Roby Bangalore and
Rosalind Syme shares in every station
every station it is the main team
reporting crime sign in that country in
the last 72 hours as Ellis brought out a
lot of people talk about the fact that
oh why would aliens go to a planet with
70% water where it's there the thing
that kills them here's a couple theories
I have number one the aliens may have
never encountered water in their life
ever they may not even know what water
is that may have been their very first
encounter with something that is harmful
to their skin number two you think about
the timeline of this movie how much time
actually happens in this movie it's
really only a couple of days the movie
starts out there's the crop circle a
couple days later the aliens are leaving
Earth and then leaving their wounded
behind within a couple days they were on
earth and realized about all this stuff
and probably very quickly obviously and
then left immediately so I mean they
were obviously desperate they left some
of their own men behind as you saw at
the end of the film the thing with the
two fingers cut off they were obviously
extremely desperate and looking for
someplace to survive some kind of
resources something as soon as they
discovered that it was a harmful place
to be they left the point of this movie
however is not the alien invasion it's
the family's plight throughout this
struggle it's what they deal with it's
how they deal with it so they come
together closer as a family and as a
unit that's why this movie is so
brilliant because it doesn't focus on
the Independence Day aspect of the film
which would have been fun too it focuses
on the family and how it
and it's so well directed and edited I
love this movie it's one of those films
that when it's on you kind of want to
turn off all the lights and watch late
at night because it's a fun scary movie
it's not gonna mess with your head too
much but it will creep you out and it
will make you think I'm not sure if I
want ET coming to earth anymore
it's it's a really great movie and don't
judge em night by jest his later films
just remember that the guy could knock
it out of the park with signs with even
unbreakable is pretty cool and obviously
the Sixth Sense was great so you know
give the guy a chance
also underrated in the film signs is the
comedy in it and if you don't think the
comedy plays a big part in horror movies
go into a theater and watch one of the
paranormal activities and see it you
need that laughter to kind of it helps
people relax then and then they get they
let their guard down a little bit and
then the scares are even better you know
any horror movie watch Freddy Krueger
half the time the guys doing stand-up
comedy when he's not killing teenagers
even a little leprechaun he runs around
like a like an open-mike er yeah he's
not really funny but he's trying they're
staying in the shadows
it's going fro let's make sure things
are clear two for one for the rest of
them there's a moose traps I'm moving
here's a glass of water
James Newton Howard scores on my
favorite scores of all time the opening
title sequence this movie is very
reminiscent of Alfred Hitchcock's Psycho
the thing about sides the opening titles
is the movie starts out so slow and with
titles like that it's hinting that that
type of intensity is coming later in the
film as the movie builds and progresses
you know suspense so you just keeps
thinking about those opening titles like
it's gonna get intense like that it's
like a warning almost to what's coming
later in the movie and one of the first
independent films I've ever made I was a
young teenager trying to remake signs so
I Oh lots of the movie I agree with all
is very much on this film and I think
that Ellis hit the nail on the head and
we talked about Shama because I still I
that guy has that type of filmmaking in
him and I really think that if he starts
directing movies and not reading the
script that it'll be a lot better guess
what his next movies with Will Smith and
Jane Smith and he ain't right in the
script
he's just directing so maybe he finally
realized that let's hope but science
gets an a-plus for me it's one of my
favorite movies of all time if I'm gonna
Schmo signs i I have a decimal system
where it's very particular so I don't
just go forward four and a half and five
but it doesn't even matter it's five out
of five Moe's for signs I don't give
five out of five to barely ever and it's
just one of those movies maybe it hit me
at the right time I'm willing to admit
that I'm a human it but I love this
movie and I think it is maybe my one of
my favorite alien invasion movies one of
my favorite horror films of all time and
hit to a fault it'll make me pay for it
much Shyamalan okay even though that's
they're better too and I just say that
oh well I want to thank Mark Ellis he is
a great reviewer and he's also a really
good guy so if you haven't subscribed to
the schmoes and I would definitely go
check them out they're worth your time
for sure and they'll entertain you
endlessly
round forces are being assembled
your friend spike worth world so leave
its kind of passion a friend
come
thanks again to Chris for letting me
participate in this in this with him I'm
always happy to talk to a fellow car
freak and science is definitely one of
the ones it's up there maybe it's not
you don't think of it as a horror movie
maybe it's more of an alien sci-fi movie
this movie definitely has as many scares
and thrills and chills as any other
horror movie that I've ever seen not
named The Exorcist thanks a lot I
appreciate your help mark and thanks my
viewers for watching I will continue
with more stuckman scary movie nights
despite how corny that title is but if
you liked this review you can subscribe
to my channel and get steppen highs
you